let's bring in trey gowdy he's a fox
news contributor and host of the trey
gowdy podcast so
i remember a while ago trey when you
talked about
the need for rationality and also
in your book where you write talking
about persuasion
i think rationality comes to mind so i
was thinking about that today
listen to admiral gerard this morning
talking about these rules
what really breaks my heart is that i
don't know of any data that says you
need to shut down
outdoor dining or outdoor bars we really
wanted to limit the
indoor crowded places so um i think we
need to do what's necessary to turn the
pandemic
but not more that's not evidence-based
trey is that rational
uh you know danny you put your finger on
the right word i mean americans for what
two centuries now have proven they are
willing to sacrifice for the betterment
of other people
but there has to be a rational
connection between what you're being
asked to do
and the desired outcome that's what
frustrates people is when there's no
rationality you're just doing it because
you have the power to do it
and the other thing that people find
incredibly frustrating is the hypocrisy
that the leaders don't follow the rules
that they set for others i mean
you think about the jurisdictions where
you can go watch
mystique or destiny at a strip club but
you can't go see the virgin mary on the
wall at your church
so so there has to be rationality
there has to be a willingness from the
leaders you know good leaders dana you
actually work for one
good leaders are the first to pick up a
heavy task and the last to put it down
they are not eating in fancy french
restaurants in california while they're
telling everybody else they can't do it
the other thing that i thought you would
want to comment on is you know we've
been
saying on this program for a while and
others here at the channel
as well the need for some coveted relief
for the people who
really need it it's been on hold
and speaker pelosi today sort of
revealed her hand watch this
what was then before was not more of
this
this is has simplicity it's what we've
had in our bills
it's for a shorter period of time but
that's okay now
because we have a new president
so it's okay now because there's a new
president trey
that's one of the dumbest uh and also
most despicable things i have ever heard
an alleged leader
say that because joe biden won it's okay
to do it but if donald trump had won
i mean when you're suffering when you're
like an economic self-defense mode you
don't care about politics
you just want to keep your business
going your family fed you don't want to
be evicted from your home so
the notion that somehow or another
because her team
won in november that she's going to do
something
what's missing dana is that paul ryan or
john boehner
had said or done what she just said
there would be media outcry
and other than fox um what other entity
has commented
on what the speaker of the house just
said because biden one
will do it but while it was trump we
weren't going to give him a victory i
mean it really
is so outrageous it's hard to get me
upset
but what she just said uh makes me
madder than hell
the other thing is it takes a while to
get these payments processed
so the fact that they might actually get
something done before christmas means
that you're looking at another
four weeks which is super frustrating as
well trey
i'm ran out of time uh talk to you soon
thank you